hey guys Oh righteous Ryan here uh come
up with something yeah
judgmental Dan [ __ ] judgmental dick well
that's what my name is ass Dan means
judgment does it yeah how horrible
good job Christianity pulled through on
this one he's awesome we're gonna watch
the trailer day the silent hill's TGS
2014 trailer a case you guys don't know
TGS is the genital station a broadcast
all talk shows about genitalia it is
awesome
somehow Silent Hill screeners have
collaborated with TGS and supposedly
really get more genital action in this
one Tokyo Game Show that's what it
stands for I was gonna that's what it
stands for we talked about this like six
times before we started I don't so
there's no such thing as a giant cell
you know station I just wish really
harder to wish ah oh I see what I did
there was she kind of proud of myself
well like the previous trailer I saw for
this game Dan likes playing it right Dan
Hays playing because he gets scared
easily [ __ ] I'm the same way don't
worry let's watch this
et concept movie
why this vegan Spanish that's Japanese
bro congratulation
walk away walk away walk away let it
look so pretty
walk away
go dear man I was pretty [ __ ] freaky
walk away but it looks so pretty
Oh
oh she's a blood on the wall yep
where's he gonna walk - Wow go in uh
she's really take this time it has a
suitcase just go I'm not gonna close the
door man
I love Japan well that was um quite a
nightmarish experience [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that it's just like haunting [ __ ] that
hike to this game just knows these game
makers really know how to put you into
an environment a state of mind of state
of fear through imagery it's amazing
it's respectable it just looks too damn
real that's the problem with it that is
literally the bomb baby destroyed now
it's too goddamn real I I act honestly
I'm not gonna lie to you guys I say I
want to play it I might not though
because I get too [ __ ] scared [ __ ]
like as much as I want to be like you
don't get me wrong great trailer great
effects totally gets the job done
that is exactly why I might not play
it's too real man it's too real too
goddamn real which do get to not not I
can't I won't I don't want to well
thanks for all you people telling us
this trailer was that thank you
if you're new the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects we keep it
real and you can subscribe a dance
channel that cyber channel you know he's
on hiatus right now but he'll be coming
back soon
like Arnold Schwarzenegger I'll be back
as my Arnold impression I'm Arnold yeah
you're Arnold get through the side but
get to this down get to now
Larry Stan bog off Stan Bock I'm Stan
bog I was dying what I'm a huge fan of
your channel he was laughing in
something I'm always checking your
channel for new videos you guys do
amazing work and it would be an ultimate
honor to get a shout-out from you guys
Larry you sound kinda Jewish I don't
think we can give you a shot
it's [ __ ] around I love all you Jews
you jeez make me laugh you're the main
reason there's a movie business so I
need to respect you guys that much is
very true yeah so if you need me to be
Jewish
I could be Jewish well I am I was gonna
say you have the curly hair you probably
have to say much I have the curly hair I
got the curly hair I'm also very cheap
and I get a lot of money for my birthday
do you like bacon no oh there you go
no I hate bacon kosher exactly and I get
Costco hot dogs cuz they're kosher yeah
yeah they are aren't they
hey they honor kosher 100% beef hot dogs
huh let's move on come on
thanks Larry you're good guy thanks
Larry
Ethan Montgomery I owe Ryan he's a
[ __ ] man let me get a shout-out up in
this [ __ ] letter listen if she's fine
keep it real player
yeah Alyssa's fine I'll send her a text
message or something thanks man you're
the [ __ ] man yeah you can get a
shout-out up in this [ __ ] that's what I
call a shout-out section my [ __ ] do you
bend it over a table I bent it over a
table smack its ass and say you my [ __ ]
and then it turns around and says I am a
respectable human being yeah you
apologize profusely apologize profusely
and I give them money to shut their
[ __ ] mouth anyway Ethan Ethan Hawke
cheated on uma Thurman so I'm gonna
assume that all Ethan's are dicks I
think you're a respectable human being
okay Samuel Oh
Ryan they said a lot of things about why
I should watch something and please a
shout out will be cool
Samuel oh our people ever like Oh Samuel
like you walk through the door and
you're like Oh Samuel and they're like
no it's reversed do you get confused
like that is this real last name was
really complicated and he just like
surprised people so it's just like
Samuel Oh
I'd be really cool that dude I loved
last thing I would make a bunch of jokes
about it my last names right and
whatever I can to insert the word right
it's a funny ass most hilarious moment
of my life
and I suggest you do the same without
you know like you be banging a girl
should be like oh and it might be like
that's my family name shut up say Samuel
just really confused she kept crying out
my last name isn't even know my first
name isn't the whole family she likes ha
ha
I think she's bagging my bro